souvent les élèves cherchent des
informations des données statistiques
pour agrémenter pour construire leurs
travaux de géographie ils vont sur
internet et chercher un peu comme des
poules sans tête sans savoir exactement
ce qu'ils cherchent
je vous propose aujourd'hui dans cette
vidéo de découvrir un excellent tout dit
l'atlas statistiques du site
eurostat génériques je vous propose de
vous rendre tout de suite sur google de
taper ac la statistique et vous
retrouvez directement le lien qui vous
est proposé vous cliquez évidemment
dessus vous allez voir l'outil est très
sympathique puisque en fait vous arrivez
directement sur des cartes alors ce qui
est intéressant avec ses cartes c'est
qu'elles sont découpées on n'a pas
simplement des données statistiques pour
des pays
on a des données statistiques pour les
régions donc ce qui nous permet de voir
vraiment les disparités intra étatique
ce qui est demandé au cours de
géographie quoi alors vous avez
plusieurs outils évidemment comme bien
sûr la capacité de changer l'échelle ça
c'est toujours très appréciable
évidemment moi je vous que je vous
conseille pour vos travaux pour
agrémenter votre à vos c'est d'utiliser
la capture d'écran alors j'utilise ici
la capture d'écran windows
évidemment chacun utilisera la capture
comme ça vous pouvez directement
utiliser votre image en copier coller
dans vos travaux et l'un portait
évidemment n'oubliez pas de mentionner
les sources
qu'ils soient ici ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les sources foyer elles sont
directement mentionner ici en bas et
donc pas de soucis pour pour retrouver
ces informations alors vous allez
choisir les variables que vous souhaitez
afficher et sécu dans le chapitre
population et c'est l'espérance de vie à
la naissance
alors on pourra aller regardez par
exemple ce qui se passe en termes
d'économie parce que souvent ce qu'on
veut connaître
voilà vous avez chapitre 6 économie par
exemple le pib par habitant est ici vous
avez le pib par habitant par rapport à
la moyenne européenne donc c'est un
indice ça veut dire qu'ici 100
représente la moyenne du pib par
habitant des vaincus pays de l'union
européenne
dans le cas qui nous occupe ici
actuellement en 2017 2018 avec les
reto du collage visitation lamberdière
on s'intéresse au cas de la catalogne
est donc voyez ici que la catalogne d'un
pib nettement supérieure au reste du
pays
si ce n'est la capitale évidemment mais
vous voyez que toutes les capitales
toutes les régions situées près des
capitales différents états ont un pib
supérieur ce sont les tâches que vous
voyez à chaque fois mais vous voyez que
c'est capital ont toujours un pib
supérieur
ce qu'on voit d'autres ici par exemple
en espagne c'est le pays basque et le
pays basque a aussi des volonté
d'indépendance comme la catalogne
donc voyez cette carte est déjà très
intéressante de ce point de vue là on
peut faire le même le même lien avec
l'italie le nord de l'italie
ou bien la flandre évidemment chez nous
donc en cliquant comme ça sur les
différentes variables vous allez avoir
chaque fois les données statistiques
mais pour chaque unité territoriale ce
qu'on appelle les minutes et vous allez
avoir les nutt un nu dieu et jusqu'à 3
évidemment en us 3 c'est vraiment un
découpage très tout petits seins vous
aurez région du dieu vous aurez d'autres
ici vous voyez que c'est bind 2 donc on
a l'information ici que vous est donné
par nice 2 voilà donc vous voyez un
outil très facile à utiliser que vous
pourrez je l'espère utilisé à bon
escient pour vos prochains travaux
cette vidéo est fini si vous avez des
questions n'oubliez pas les commentaires
je vous souhaite un bon travail et à
très bientôt
[Musique]